>>female presenter: Michael is a linguist.
And, like many linguists, I'm a linguist as
well, he claims to be monolingual.
Now, what is a linguist?
If someone finds out you're a linguist, what's
the first question they ask?
"How many languages do you speak?"
And I always answer, "Well, I've studied,
I don't know, 5 maybe.
I've studied Spanish, Russian, German."
You have a list you start going like this.
And you say, "But I don't speak any of them.
But I've studied them."
So when Michael's book came out about hyperpolyglots,
I thought, "How many can there possibly be?"
I think I met one in graduate school.
My dissertation advisor.
But it ended up not being a very interesting
question as I followed Michael through his
book.
And you'll see it becomes far more interesting
than simply that question.
Michael has advanced degrees in linguistics
and rhetoric.
He's lived in South America and in Asia, where
he taught English as a second language.
He joins us today to talk about his book Babel
No More.
That's apparently the American version.
The search for the world's most extraordinary
language learners.
So please join me in welcoming Michael.
[applause]
>>Michael Erard: Thanks.
And thanks to everyone for coming.
Thanks to Anne for setting this up.
It's good to see some friends, old friends,
in the audience as well.
So as she said, I'm trained as a linguist,
but for about the last decade, I've been writing
stories about language and languages and the
people who use and study them.
The most recent story is Babel No More, which
is a book about hyperpolyglots.
So in the presentation, I want to run through
some of the high points from the book.
Some stuff that characterizes this group of
people specifically, that you might know if
you are one of these people that you might
not know either way.
I'll just second what Anne said, which is
that I am not a hyperpolyglot or a polyglot
in any regard.
People I think have said, "How could a monoglot
write a book about this without really understanding?"
Once you get and spend a little bit of time
around the hyperpolyglot world and that community,
you realize how many people really have a
stake, a personal stake, in claiming and proving
that they have lots of languages.
In some ways, this is a book that can only
be written by someone who doesn't have any
of those claims to make whatsoever.
I have nothing to prove.
Well, that's not true.
I have a lot to prove, but not in that regard.
[pause]
When you think of massive multilingual people
or entities, you might think of this guy.
Anyone remember how many languages he has?
>>audience member: Over 6 million.
>> Michael Erard: Over 6 million, yeah.
He claims.
[laughter] And a lot of them were languages
of pumps, so how complex can that be?
But 6 million of them.
This is another tool that is making people
much more multilingual out in the world.
64 languages, now.
Only 64 languages.
But I hope that after my talk and after you
read the book that you will think of this
guy when you think of massive multilingualism.
This is Cardinal Giuseppe Mezzofanti, an Italian
priest and cardinal who was born in 1774.
He died in 1849.
He spoke, what is commonly and usually attributed
to him, 72 languages or 114 languages, depending
on who you talk to.
I love how I said "72 languages" and all the
chewing stopped.
[laughter]
So with numbers like that, you want to go
check it out, right?
And see how much evidence there is, how much
contemporary evidence there is for actually
being able to do that in all those languages.
So I went to his archive in Bologna, Italy,
and dug around and found a lot of stuff that
really demonstrates that he could do a lot
of pretty advanced things in quite a lot of
languages.
Not 72 of them, however, but a lot of substantial
stuff.
And a lot of really other interesting stuff,
such as this, which is from a legal document
that was written about 40 years after his
death when his body was disinterred from his
tomb because it was rumored to be a group
of foreign language enthusiasts who were trying
to get a hold of his skull.
So they dug him up to make sure that his body
was intact.
I think also because there might have been
a move to try to canonize Mezzofanti, and
the first step in the canonization process
in the Roman Catholic Church is to make sure
that the person's body has not been taken
for veneration by any other group.
So this is what they found, or an artist's
rendering of what they found when they opened
up Mezzofanti's tomb.
He was all there.
The other thing that I found, or another interesting
thing that I found was in another box.
Unlike the first box, I actually got to put
my hands on the inside of this one.
This was a box of packets of paper of different
sizes.
When I opened the box, the librarians were
like, "Wow, what is this stuff?"
They had apparently never seen it before.
I don't know how many people had ever seen
it, because there was no record of people
having gone in this box.
But you take apart the packets, and on each
slip-- there's collections of slips of paper,
and on one side is written a word in one language,
and on the other side is written another word.
I went, "My God, it's Mezzofanti's flashcards!"
[laughter]
So the common notion of the polyglot or the
hyperpolyglot or the talented person is that
they get this stuff by osmosis, but in his
case, anyway, it turns out to involve quite
a lot of hard work and repetitive work.
A famous guy in his time.
He was courted by Napoleon, visited by Russian
princesses and Texan colonels.
Lord Byron came and had a famous swearing
contest with him.
So it was a glamorous life for a 19th century
celibate man.
But he was also going home and, before blowing
out his candle, working through his Persian
flashcards.
And I think those two things, those two images,
of this person are really instructive.
Holding them together is very instructive.
Here's another person that I read about in
a book and who's very prominent in discussions
of hyperpolyglots.
His name is Emil Krebs, and he was a German
diplomat.
He died in 1930.
When he died, he started out finishing law
school and going to the German diplomatic
school and saying, "I want to learn all of
the languages that you have."
And they said, "Well, you can't learn all
the languages."
He said, "Okay, I want to learn the hardest
one" which was Chinese.
So in three years he was certified as a Chinese
translator and was posted to the diplomatic
mission in Beijing where the empress dowager
would ask to have him come and speak Chinese
to her because, of all the foreigners, his
Chinese was the best.
There's lots of stories about him as this
famously cranky, difficult person studying
languages all night long, parading around
his study naked, drunk on beer, which was--
and he only drank beer and he only ate meat
and nothing else.
That kind of eccentricity is something that
shows up a lot, but not as much as you would
think it would.
When he died in 1930, his family donated his
brain to science.
It's now housed in a collection of genius
brains in Duesseldorf.
When I went to see it, I was really excited,
like "Oh, there's going to be a brain floating
in a jar."
But of course it wasn't.
They had sliced and diced it a million ways.
It was studied in 1931, but then 2002, 2003
two German neuroscientists got a hold of it
again and did an analysis of the structure
of his cortical cells.
But the language dominant region of his brain,
which would have been the left side because
he was right-handed, but also on the corresponding
right side.
And what they found was a surprising density
of cell structure and a symmetry in that density
on both left and right.
They compared his brain to 11 control brains,
and that's how they made the determinations
of the density.
So it's quite an unusual brain for that reason.
But in the book, I really endeavored to try
to go meet living hyperpolyglots because the
Krebs is really interesting, and the Mezzofanti
character is really interesting.
But what could they really do?
They're dead.
We can't assess them, or whatever.
So this is a woman named Helena Bozi who works
for the World Bank.
She has studied 18 languages to intermediate
degree.
On a regular basis, she uses all the languages
of the World Bank, which is 6.
And she's a program evaluator for literacy
programs that the bank funds.
So she'll go out to Cambodia, say, in order
to assess the progress of the mission and
see how her bank money is being spent and
stuff like that.
Before she goes, she learns the language.
Not because it gets her anything.
She should just be able to use English or
some other major language or colonial language.
But she really believes that knowing those
languages helps her talk to students, understand
what students are doing, talk to teachers,
and get around the official story that the
officials would want to be telling her.
She's interesting for a couple reasons.
One, she's 61 years old, so she's definitely
on the older end of the hyperpolyglot scale.
She describes having to do a lot more repetitive
work in order to get the language stuff into
her head.
She's also interesting because she is a she.
There are very very few, relatively few women
who are hyperpolyglots, both historically
and contemporaneously.
So doing research for the book, I did an online
survey of people who said that they know 6
or more languages, and only 30% of the people
who answered are women.
There are lots of reasons, but we can speculate
about why that gap exists.
This is somebody else that I wrote about in
the book.
I posted a video on YouTube a while back of
him describing his daily polyglot workout
which starts at 2 o'clock in the morning when
he wakes up and starts working in English
and then goes through German, Russian, Hindi,
Persian, Arabic, Chinese in 15-20 minute chunks.
He won't say how many languages he speaks.
And I find that a pretty principled position
to take because one of the conclusions of
the book is how insufficient the notion of
a language is as a unitive measure.
One language does not weigh-- It doesn't have
a cognitive weight, and they don't have the
same cognitive weights as each other.
When he was a single assistant professor in
Korea, he would spend 16 hours a day working
on languages in 15-20 minute chunks, but now
he's married.
Yes, he's married.
And he has two kids.
He speaks Korean at home and he speaks French
at home to his sons.
He lives in Singapore.
He has a job.
So I assume that he's spending much less time
actually doing language learning than he used
to.
[pause]
These are hyperpolyglots.
Maybe not the prettiest word in the world.
It was coined by linguist Dick Hudson at University
College London, who was looking for a term
to capture and characterize people who spoke
6 or more languages.
And that's not an arbitrary number.
His logic was that there are communities where
everyone speaks 5 languages, from the uneducated
person to the most educated person.
It's not an extraordinary thing.
So the people who speak 6 or more must, in
those terms, be doing something that is fairly
unusual.
As you'll see, I have a slide on this in a
bit.
I think that that number should be revised
upwards to 11.
I see another poly-11 in the audience here.
So you're probably sitting there wondering,
"Okay, great.
72 languages, whatever.
What can these people actually do?"
[sighs] which was something that was really
important to me, too, because one of the goals
of the book was to try to get away from the
anecdote and get away from the exaggeration
and get away from the Guinness World Book
of Records, of Facts.
So Guinness has somehow got itself into the
business of certifying language proficiency.
If you ever need a certification, it's fairly
easy, I think, coming from Guinness.
What I did for this part was I took the inter
agency language round table scale, which is
a US federal government scale for measuring
proficiency in a number of different language
areas: reading, writing, translating, listening,
and speaking of course.
At the time that I was working on the book,
there were 3 of the scales that had been adapted
for a self-reporting scale.
So you could take yourself: can you order
a meal, yes or no?
Can you order a taxi, yes or no?
And they increase with increasing functional
difficulty.
And where 5, of course, is the educated native
speaker goal.
So that's supposed to be a goal of language
learning.
I gave this particular test to a guy named
Graham Cansdale, who was a European Commission
translator.
He's 46 or 47.
He translates in 13 languages, has studied
languages all his life.
He agreed to play along.
This is his proficiency in spoken language
and all of his languages.
What's interesting is that it's not a very
high level across all of his languages.
Some are fairly high, but a lot of them are
quite low.
People often ask, "How do speaking and reading
differ from each other?"
I gave him the reading test, and that's what
his reading proficiencies looks like.
It's higher in a lot of languages, but it
also diminishes.
What's interesting is that he's working in
3 scripts.
It's not just a bunch of languages, it's 3
scripts.
And that represents something like 8 language
families.
So it's pretty considerable.
And that higher distribution in the reading
than the speaking I think reflects a couple
things.
One is his work as a translator, so he just
gets more practice with the reading than he
does in speaking.
And also that reading in all those languages,
while a not insignificant task, also represents
less of a cognitive load than online, spoken
communication.
So it's easier to do.
Then this is his proficiency scores in the
three areas: speaking, listening, and reading
across all the languages that he has, arranged
in order of when he learned them.
So on the far left English, his native language.
French is the first one that he studied in
elementary school.
And then over on the far left, you see Chinese.
He's in Taiwan right now doing an intensive
Mandarin course.
Not just speaking but also learning how to
read and write.
And he reports that it is kicking his ass.
Learning to read and write.
Interestingly, Mezzofanti had a similar experience
with written Chinese.
He always claimed that he could speak Chinese,
but Mezzofanti had a nervous breakdown when
he was faced with trying to learn how to read
and write Chinese.
There might have been typhoid or something
like that involved as well, 'cause he had
fevers and lived in a feverish state for a
while.
And when he came out of it, he had forgotten
all of his languages, except for Bolognese,
which was his mother tongue.
He apparently got the other languages back,
but I love that story.
"Don't study Mandarin."
[laughter] Or don't learn to read or write
it.
What's also interesting about this distribution
is in this foreign language acquisition world,
there are some truisms, there are some theoretical
aspects that are reported with this graph.
Earlier learned languages are typically stronger,
and then later learned languages are typically
not.
But then you have that whole middle group
of languages which are surprisingly high.
And I also find it's interesting how much
difference there is among all the languages
stronger in one set of skills than the others.
[pause]
[sighs] So this is the imagined polyglot proficiency
profile: that they must have very high abilities
in all of the languages that they speak.
It's the additive view.
This used to be the view, and maybe still
is in some corners of even bilinguals or trilinguals
that each of those people possess a monolingual
native speaker's knowledge of a language just
glommed onto each other, and that the hyperpolyglot
is just a more extreme version of that.
I've had conversations with people saying,
"Did Mezzofanti speak 72 languages like a
native speaker?"
The implication being that if he didn't like
a native speaker, then it's not a phenomenon
that's all that interesting.
But I'm maintaining that it is really interesting,
but you need to go back and make some adjustments
to your expectations and to the way that you
count or describe success in foreign language
learning in order to make this significant.
So people's profiles typically look more like
this, where you have a few very high languages
and then decreasing over the-- as the number
of languages increases and then this long
tail where there's hardly anything at all.
But not that-- At a moment in time, this proficiency
profile is very dynamic.
Those languages that are very low over on
the right hand side, they could conceivably,
if they had had very high levels proficiency
in the past, they claim to be able to activate
them or take them off ice, thaw them out a
little bit in order to be able to use them.
I get asked a lot, "What are the hyperpolyglots
like?"
I think that, "What can you say about the
hyperpolyglots?"
I think that sometimes the question is trying
to get me to confess that they're also piano
geniuses or they're really good in bed, or
they're just odd, they're super super odd.
But I can't say any of that.
But I can say these things, these are pretty
safe generalizations to make about them: they've
learned how to learn, they've learned how
they learn and how they learn individually,
and as a result, they've discovered or invented
or swapped methods of learning that affect
them, that fit them.
They like and they crave repetition.
The repetitive work of looking at the flashcards
or doing other things is something that they're
drawn to and that they crave.
The language of addiction comes up quite a
lot, that with people who don't do this, they
get a little agitated.
Which suggests that there's a very strong
role for dopamine in this whole process, and
that these people are responding very strongly
to neurological, neuromodulatory reward.
They remember what they learn.
They have incredible memories.
They have a feel for language.
The structure of language is something that
they have at their fingertips.
And actually, this gesture that I'm doing
is one that the hyperpolyglots would do a
lot as if they were connected to their brains,
and talking about the stuff they had in their
brains in this very textured way.
They find or they make a social niche for
themselves.
Individuals who are happiest are people who
have a place where learning languages and
having a lot of languages, even with that
stair step profile, is normal and even has
a certain amount of social status.
The ones who are unhappiest are the ones who
are out in the community who don't have a
place in that sort of institution or that
sort of organization.
And the last point is one that I just recently
added after thinking about it a little bit.
What they're implicitly or explicitly what
they're doing is they're asserting a right
to not speak English.
Some of them report some frustration or difficulties
trying to work on their languages out in the
world, particularly in places where the English
is pretty good.
And they get frustrated.
I think a lot of people have either heard
or had experiences trying to work on your
Dutch.
In the Netherlands, it's really hard.
Or Swedish and things like that.
So where did I start with hyperpolyglots?
I've studied Spanish and studied Chinese and
always seen these people who were really much
better than I was, and also interested in
the cultural ideal of the person who can speak
a lot of languages and the person for whom
it's very easy.
I was interested in: what is the root of my
fascination?
What is the root of the cultural or historical
fascination with this group of people?
And it's not just a monolingual society like
the US that finds polyglots, or the UK that
finds polyglots fascinating.
I did some research for the book in South
Asia or South India where people are very
multilingual.
And I'd say, "I'm writing about this guy Mezzofanti
who spoke 72 languages."
And people'd go, "Wow, that's amazing.
You've got to talk to my uncle.
He was a diplomat and he spoke 20 languages.
He's an incredible guy."
Or "You've got to talk to this other guy who
speaks 15 languages."
So there it was-- Even this place where people
were massively multilingual themselves, there
was also this very high regard for people
who could do things with a lot of other languages
and languages that were not Indian languages.
That was the thing that was really amazing
to them.
"Wow, he can speak Russian.
He can speak Chinese.
That's really amazing."
So I was interested in exploring the relationship
that we have to that cultural ideal.
The first book that I wrote, which came out
in 2007, is a natural history of slips of
the tongue and speech disfluencies.
The uhs and the ums and things like that.
It's the search for the perfectly um-less
speaker.
Where did we even get the notion that talking
without ums is to be highly regarded?
Where did that aesthetic come from?
Because clearly, those things are necessary
elements of human communication.
If we didn't have them, we wouldn't be able
to communicate, or we would have some other
behavior that the toast masters in this alternate
universe would be trying to get rid of.
[pause]
Oh, people know toast masters.
Do you know what's interesting about toast
masters?
They can be very very good at eliminating
uhs and ums from their speech, from their
public speeches, and that carries over into
their conversation, but what ends up happening
is they develop these other mechanisms for
pausing.
They, they, they, they'll, they'll, they'll
do this.
And they never get dinged according to toast
master rules because it's all about uhs and
ums, not about repetitions.
And another reason-- I think in a lot of ways
a really big reason and a really big attraction
for me of the hyperpolyglots was just that
no one had ever taken them seriously.
It was like this "That's a giant squid which
may or may not exist.
I guess there are people that are convinced
that it does."
But the hyperpolyglot was-- People had anecdotes
or folklore about high school teachers who
could speak 18 languages and uncles, or things
like that, but no one had ever assessed, "Okay,
what can they actually do?"
So I set out to write the book to not only
write some of the anecdotes, 'cause the stories
are really cool, but to try to actually put
some numbers on this.
There's a funny moment when I'm in Italy and
I'm meeting with another guy that's an Italian
historian who's written a book about Mezzofanti
as a librarian.
And I said, "I need to count stuff."
And he's like, "You're a positivist" and he
punches me in the shoulder.
"You're a positivist."
"Well, yeah."
And he's like, "Yeah, you're a positivist."
So another reason to pay attention to the
hyperpolyglots is that we need them.
We need to understand the cognitive capital
that they have and how they got it and how
they wield it.
In all of this, I'm really interested in the
question of how do you make more language
learners?
How do you make more better languages learners?
Not just in the US, but everywhere.
Learning languages is the human condition
in a lot of ways right now.
And not just learning human languages, but
learning machine languages as well.
So the way that I tell that story in the book
is through this notion of the neural tribe.
It's a way of starting with the notion that
human brains are all different from each other.
That's actually an evolutionary asset of the
species.
Because we have different brains, we learn
differently, we solve problems in different
ways.
The people who are very good at learning languages
or doing some similar behavior is one of those
types of brains.
They are selected by certain kinds of environments
in order to be able to wield the particular
neurology that they have.
There are a number of ways to characterize
that neurology.
In the book, I speculate a lot about directions
that that might take, including plasticity,
including particular memory function, so hippocampal,
something special about the hippocampus and
other things.
They're selected by the environment.
It's a nondeterministic account.
I'm not saying that if you have that brain,
you'll become a hyperpolyglot.
You have to have that brain and you have to
have access to those resources, be living
in a culture where this is a given status,
or whatever.
Those things start to feed back on each other.
And what that does is it creates an identity,
a sense of an "I", like, "Hey, I'm a language
learner.
This is what I do."
And then a sense of a personal mission, like
"I'm going to start traveling to these places.
I'm going to cook up a project that involves
lots of languages.
I'm going to be on the lookout for native
speakers in those languages because I like
to practice that."
[pause]
Another thing that's crucial about the neural
tribe is that they're these extra-institutional
or subnational.
I mean, they are very tribal in that sense.
The way that they learn languages and the
things that they use their languages for are
largely not things that institutions find
valuable.
Doing research for the project, I went to
the Defense Language Institute and the Foreign
Service Institute, and said, "Hey, polyglots.
You know any polyglots?"
And they're just not interested in the people
who can speak lots of languages to fairly
low levels of proficiency, because their whole
task is about taking adults, taking monolingual
English speaking adults and turning them into
bilinguals who can work as diplomats or spies,
people who can blend in to whatever the native
population is.
This is a total different orient.
According to those institutional rules, they
hyperpolyglot looks like a failed language
learner.
[pause] And being extra-institutional in this
way also gives them the freedom to basically
be experimenting on themselves cognitively
and pedagogically, inventing stuff, trying
stuff out that might work with them on their
brains.
So these are some results from the survey
that I did.
On the left, you have people who know more
than 6 languages, and I left that however
they wanted to report that.
That was fine.
On the left are people who reported that learning
languages was easier for them than for other
people.
In both groups, the number of men is 70%.
They're not all that old, but I was surprised
to see that many people in the 25-40 year
old range, 'cause I had thought that maybe,
if you have this neurology, that that would
have been something that was siphoned off
by access to programming environments and
programming professions and stuff like that.
Maybe it is, maybe it isn't.
And I don't know how much of an overlap there
is.
I can talk about it a little bit.
But I was surprised to see so many young people
in both groups.
Multilingualism is not necessarily a precursor
to hyperpolyglotism.
Some people start that way, but not all of
them do.
Then, as far as IQ distribution, I mistrust
that.
These were self-reported IQs.
That seems really high to me.
But I just stick it here.
They were from all over the world.
The survey was in English.
It was circulated on English language blogs.
I don't think that it really got that far
into Asia or the non-English part of the internet.
It's an unreliable sample in a lot of ways.
This is that chart of repertoire size or collection
size that I was talking about before.
I have a bunch of people with 60 languages
and then decreasing numbers, but it really
bottoms out at 11, so that for me is maybe
the new floor or what it means or what it
requires to be a hyperpolyglot: about 11 languages.
Those two other graphs there are what's the
contribution of being or growing up with more
than one mother tongue, and then what's the
contribution of talent or something innate
versus something else.
The contribution of talent is much higher
than growing up with more than one mother
tongue.
These are some characteristics of that group
who had more than 11 languages.
Overwhelmingly male.
They were an older group, which makes sense.
I mean, it takes you a little more time to
accumulate all of the languages.
But I'll just go back to this.
The highest number that I got reported was
26 languages, so the next time you meet somebody
who says, "Yeah, I speak 50 languages", keep
that into account.
[pause]
I asked people to, this is a cross of the
two groups: of people with more than 6 languages
who said that learning is easier for them.
There were 145 of them.
I asked them why they thought that was the
case.
"Innate talent, I'm intelligent, I work harder,
I'm more motivated, it's part of my background,
I have a good education, I like languages,
my parents are good language learners."
People were not giving very much credit to
their parents and giving a ton of credit to
attitude, or what looks like attitude.
"I like languages.
I'm the 90%."
But I'm really curious: what does "I like
languages" actually mean?
It's "I like the way that my mouth sounds
or the way that my mouth feels when I speak
Japanese."
Or is it "I like the way that a member-- or
another attractive person looks at me when
I speak Japanese."
Or "I like the way that my brain feels when
I'm doing-- when I'm trying to speak Japanese
or when I'm learning Japanese" or things like
that.
That high number doesn't surprise me, but
I wouldn't say that that is entirely all attitude,
positive attitude about foreign languages
or being multilingual necessarily.
One of the explanations that's been offered
for this particular neurology is called the
Geschwind-Galaburta Hypothesis.
It was first developed in the '80s.
The story goes like this: that at a particular
moment in the developing fetus, the presence
of or exposure to a certain level of testosterone
changes and creates-- changes the migration
of neural cells in the brain and creates these
patterns of impairments/gifts so that you
can end up with someone who is visuo-spacialy
gifted but verbally impaired, or vice versa.
And that vice versa case could potentially
be the hyperpolyglot.
It was originally formulated in order to try
to combine some of the insights or some observed
correlations between things like left-handedness
and immune disorders, or left-handedness and
maleness, or maleness and dyslexia.
It's an attempt to give a global explanation
to all of those phenomena.
I asked Geschwind-Galaburta questions on the
survey and did not find anything interesting
or significant statistically except in two
areas.
One: people were reporting higher levels of
immune disorders, either for themselves or
for their families, than was statistically
predicted.
And also higher levels of homosexual identification,
behavior, or orientation than was predicted.
It's a problematic set of questions, to be
sure, because measuring handedness turns out
to not be [pause] all that straightforward.
Certainly, asking the homosexuality question,
you've got to be really careful.
So I'll just-- I should have prefaced that,
but I'll postface that and say-- I'm not saying
that people who are hyperpolyglots are gay,
I'm saying-- or left-handed or anything, I'm
saying that this particular theory says that,
predicts that it's about likelihood.
It's about probability.
And it's about not necessarily probability
in an individual but in the family.
[pause]
So these are some of the implications, I think.
Just some of the implications of some of this.
One of which is for language learning in general.
Obviously I get a lot of questions about "What
is the hyperpolyglot secret?"
And the secret is, unfortunately, there is
no secret that is global or uniform.
What you do have are secrets that are particular
to individuals, I think.
One of the ways to find that out is to really
work on profiling yourself.
What are your learner preferences?
What is your cognitive style?
And then going out and finding methods that
work for you and prove your higher order cognitive
skills.
Get working on that working memory trainer
and executive function trainer.
You could be working on a language and doing
your dual end back iPhone app on the treadmill,
and the two things will arguably or theoretically
be enhancing each other.
The federal government is working on research
exactly in this area and showing a very high
degree of correlation between language aptitude
and working memory skills.
The degree to which you can get your working
memory stronger, your language learning will
go better.
There's this cycle of emotional preparation.
There's the neuromodulation, managing dopamine
and other kinds of things, thinking about--
starting to think about the role of hormones
in the role of language learning.
It can take an interesting spin on some language
learning folklore, so that the whole notion
that the best way to learn a foreign language
is to get a lover who speaks the other language,
which you think of as-- you want to impress
them.
It's about access to certain kinds of native
performances and things like that.
It's also about oxytocin.
It's also about maybe mimicking or jacking
up oxytocin levels as an adult that would
have been present as a child learning a language.
It's reduplicating that hormonal environment.
And two other things build community.
Learning languages is not just something that
individuals do or should undertake but something
that they're doing with other people.
These are some, I think, broader policy questions.
These are some questions more for the foreign
language learning group.
Some theoretical things as well.
I'll just close with this, which is a line
from the book: what are humans?
Are we inherently multilingual, and has that
just been squashed by the monolingual nation-state?
Are we looking towards some sort of post-national
utopia where the monolingual nation-states'
boot is being lifted from people's brains
and we're expanding back into our multilingual
right?
I think that's some of why or some of what
is so fascinating about the hyperpolyglot,
because they seem to be these fossils from
the past, but also contain or speak to what
human potential actually is and the potential
that's coming.
Thanks very much.
That's the end of my talk.
I know people always usually have really--
want to talk and have some interesting questions,
so I'm going to leave some time for that too.
[applause]
Thanks.
>>male #1: I wanted to ask, well, I wanted
to bring up: do you think with globalization
that people are going to become more multilingual
or simply settle into a few combinations?
[inaudible]
>> Michael Erard: I think that, so my argument
would be that you're certainly going to see
more hyperpolyglots, because what you have
are the proliferation environments and the
proliferation of resources that people have
access to.
That would give that neurology something to
work on.
>>male #2: I guess this is a related question,
but have you seen anything about the increase
or decrease in the rates of polyglots recently
with the rise of the internet and all these
technologies like Google Translate, Skype,
Google+ Hangouts, things like that where it's
much, much easier to build communities with
people in other countries and other languages?
>>Michael Erard: Yeah, I think it's huge.
I think it's exploding.
These used to be people who were isolated
from their communities and where being a hyperpolyglot,
even in a multilingual community, to add one
language, to add another language brings you
further away from your community.
But the internet gives people the power and
the license such that when they learn another
language, they're actually becoming part of
a community.
It's a broader global community.
It's still imagined, it's still not there.
Sometimes, and increasingly, those communities
are polyglot communities or hyperpolyglot
communities.
You can go on YouTube and you can search for
polyglot videos.
There's a whole set of rituals and performances
that they do for each other.
Quite a lot of hazing that goes on.
I don't know if you saw the stuff about this
16 year old kid, Tim Doner, from New York
City, who was profiled in March.
He claims to speak 23 languages and had done
some stuff online.
And the kid just got criticized up and down
by the older folks who were part of the community.
And really hazing him in a way was a fascinating
phenomena.
It looks like everything has settled down.
But yeah, absolutely, there are more of them.
>>male #3: I'm interested in what you found
out about the decay in ability.
I used to lead a team of people who had to
speak a lot of languages.
We had one guy who, on his resume, was 22.
We actually tested him with native speakers,
and he could do 10 fluently according to native
speakers.
>>Michael Erard: 10 fluently?
>>male #3: Yes.
>>Michael Erard: Yeah, well.
>>male #3: So it seems like there's a difference.
Some people have this decay and some people
don't.
I'd be interested in what you saw in your
research.
>>Michael Erard: Yes.
I mean, there is the decay, and it's connected
to practice, but it's also linked to that
issue that people have of feeling really confident
and being able to resuscitate or reactivate
the languages with just a little bit of time.
For them, it was almost like they could introspect.
They could feel that the language was still
there.
They could get it back very easily.
>>male #3: So out of the ones that could speak
20, how many were fluent or close to fluent
in all 20, and how many had some decay after,
say, 5?
>>Michael Erard: The ability to speak, to
have lots of languages activated at the same
time is an executive function question and
a working memory question.
There seems to be an architecture to executive
function such that it just caps that ability
at a certain point.
I think that it's 5-9, regardless of the overall
size of the repertoire that people were limited
to just on a daily basis where they don't
have to do any active, any-- maybe this gets
to your question-- any active study in order
to be able to speak that number of languages.
In the book, I write about these two contests
that were held in Belgium.
One in 1987 and one in 1990, where people
were tested in all the languages they knew.
The two guys who won both years had some amount
of 22 languages.
When I first heard that, I was like, "Oh,
that's incredible."
To be able to just walk into a room, have
a 10 minute conversation, 5 minute break,
10 minute conversation, 5 minute break, across
22 languages.
But when I actually ended up speaking to them,
it was clear that they didn't live their lives
like that.
They had 5 or 6 languages just on a regular
basis.
For the purposes of the contest, they had
really revved their engines up, but the next
day they went back to their regular lives.
>>male #4: So it seems like both you and some
of the hyperpolyglots that you interviewed
place a really high emphasis on getting speech
sounds of the language right.
You talked about shadowing with Alexander,
he's like, "Do it more Italian."
So if I were learning a new language, I would
think that getting the accent right would
be one of the last things that I would do.
Because it needs to be functional, but still
have an accent.
Especially if it was a language like English,
which has tons of different accents.
Can you explain why you place such a high
value on getting that accent right as one
of the first steps?
>>Michael Erard: Hmm.
I don't know that I would necessarily say
that.
What I found that was interesting about--
When I asked the people in the survey how
they defined knowing a language, when they
talked about world communication, they didn't
say anything about doing anything like a native
does, including pronunciation.
A lot of them-- People like Alexander, he'll
say, "I want to be familiar with the sounds
of the language, but I'm not necessarily going
to be so focused.
So what if I have an accent?"
There were a couple people that said, "Actually
sounding, getting the accent really, really
right before the rest of your skills are really
good can get you in some dangerous situations."
So you walk in-- I can say "Bonjour" pretty
well in Quebec, like "Bonjour."
"Oh, bonjour!" and [mumbles gibberish] [laughter]
So you don't want to be too good too early.
>>male #5: I had a question about the discrete
counting of individual languages.
I remind of a story of a linguistic professor
at Columbia who was asked one time, "How many
languages do you speak?"
Taken aback, he said, "I speak all languages
of Europe."
This gave me the impression that once you
learn some number, especially with related
verbs like languages of Europe, then you have
some sort of understanding, insight about
the rest of the languages, and you might be
able to speak one even you've never even come
across before.
Is that really true or do you spend a lot
of time developing some particular words to
each language and then you switch to some
other line?
>>Michael Erard: Research shows that people
who are bilingual or multilingual, on a community
basis or family basis, do acquire other languages
easier.
There are reasons for that.
The hyperpolyglots report the same sort of
thing.
It took 5 or 6 languages for them to be able
to have the additional boost.
It's a matter of, okay, given this grammatical
structure, what do I anticipate also being
true?
And then basically building a little hypothesis
in your head and confirming that or not.
>>male #5: So when you can speak, say, 22
languages like you were talking about, does
that really have any meaning?
Or is this really just about being able to
speak in 22 different accents of related languages?
>>Michael Erard: Can you ask that again, because
there's a couple ways that I take that.
>>male #5: I was just wondering what does
it really mean to say, "I speak 22 languages"
versus another couple that may be very,
>>Versus 25 or "I have 27 languages and you
only have 25, so I'm smarter than you."
>>male #5: You may only have 16, but the rest
of them are just different accents.
>>Michael Erard: That's an incredible question.
What's interesting is you can back that down
to smaller numbers of languages.
What does it mean to say that a monolingual
English speaker-- English is this huge language
that so many people have access to and they
can reproduce lots of different dialects,
they can understand them, they can move up,
they can reproduce, they can talk with a lot
of registers.
They only have one language, though.
"You puny little American."
But there are people who, oh, they speak 6
languages.
But then you dig into that 6 and the vocabularies
in those languages are pretty small and they
use them for these narrow things and they
have, the languages that they speak a lot
and the other ones that they say that they
know, it's very receptive.
Their abilities are more receptive.
So unless you dig into the complexity of what,
that's why relying on the numbers of languages
is this total convenience that's really inconvenient,
or the other way around.
'Cause it hides a lot more than it actually
reveals about what people have in their heads
and what they're able to do.
>>male #2 again: I thought another thing that
you said that was interesting was that people
like the Foreign Service Institute, the Defense
Language Institute aren't interested in polyglots.
Some of the language learning that I've seen
are things like Barry Farber's "How to Learn
Any Language."
It sounds like this guy's at least in some
sense a hyperpolyglot.
He teaches you all these techniques.
Are the techniques that you use really only
going to give you-- are they tuned to hyperpolyglots
in getting a superficial understanding, or
are the techniques he uses to learn a language
the same techniques that the Defense Language
Institute uses?
What are the differences in the two teaching
methodologies, learning pedagogies?
>>Michael Erard: I think DLI in that approach
really imagines a more, a very uniform language
acquisition process.
>>male #2: But are they doing the same things,
or are they, because they have different--
Do they have different targets or are they
actually using different techniques to learn
the languages?
>>Michael Erard: different targets and different
techniques.
[pause]
>>female #1: I'm curious if there is any correlations
between if you're a hyperpolyglot, if you're
more sensitive with culture issues, because
they're more easily, compared to us, they're
more easily to access different cultures.
>>Michael Erard: It was a question about culture.
You said, given their abilities in a lot of
different languages, do they also have the
same or heightened knowledge of culture as
well?
This depends.
It depends on who they are and what they're
interested in.
Some of them are really interested in the
culture of the language, and some of them
it's just-- They're learning the structure.
They're learning the grammar and the sounds.
>>male #6: So you had Esperanto in the mix,
which is an artificial language.
Why did you not have C++ in the mix?
[laughter] Or, to say it differently, programming
languages, while they are less complex in
some ways than natural language, they do involve
a lot of the same cognitive involvement to
actually learn them.
The same techniques that have worked for learning
French work actually for learning programming
languages.
Could you talk about that a little?
>>Michael Erard: That's my next book, really.
I've seen some discussions about how many
languages can people program in and stuff
like that.
I asked people who were hyperpolyglots if
they also programmed, if they played musical
instruments, and there was a little bit of
overlap.
Some of those questions, I don't really talk
about them that much because it seemed like
people were giving the socially acceptable
answer rather than the real answer, in some
ways.
If people wanted to-- I said, "How many languages
do you know?"
And I didn't get anyone who reported a programming
language.
If they had, I might have put it on the--
I might have included it, but it happened
very, very rarely.
So there's that issue.
And I think what's also interesting is-- I
think the trend towards speaking a lot of
languages to some level of proficiency in
order to be able to manage your Facebook feed
or to manage these emerging forms of interaction,
particularly online, is really analogous to
the polyglot programming thing and those arguments.
Is the hyperpolyglot programmer just someone
who doesn't have a lot of languages very,
very well?
Are they failed programmers or is there a
virtuosity in their multilinguistic skills?
I'd be interested in finding out more and
writing some about polyglot programming.
>>female #2: I have a question from one of
our BC rooms dialed in.
They want you to talk a little bit more about
the relationship between a language and living
at a particular place.
Did you find that the hyperpolyglots lived
in the places where the countries whose languages
that they spoke?
>>Michael Erard: I think there's a slide about
that.
[pause] It really varied.
Some of them had traveled extensively and
lived for long periods of time in places where
there were languages that they had.
But of the 17 people who had more than 11
languages, 62% of them were living in the
same country where they were born, so there
was not a huge amount of mobility there.
>>male #7: What's the highest-- or the polyglot
with the most languages who was basically
illiterate in all of them?
Who just learned it all orally.
>>Michael Erard: Oh, that's interesting.
The people that I've described in that contest
in Belgium in '87 and '90, they weren't illiterate,
but they were doing oral-- they were performing
orally.
In both cases 22 languages.
I take the second guy, his performance, to
be a little more meaningful or powerful or
whatever because the rules were different.
The rules were stricter.
In the first case, the hyperpolyglots had,
the contestants had this ability to go in
and start talking about whatever they wanted
to, and the judges let them do that.
In the second contest, the judges were explicitly
instructed, whatever the person starts talking,
get them off that topic.
They're going to just talk to their strengths,
but you want to get them, move them off.
That's actually one of the ways that oral
proficiency interviews are conducted.
I take the second guy's performance as more
telling.
So 22 languages.
That doesn't get to your question exactly,
and I know we're drawing to-- but I didn't
find anybody who was illiterate in all their
languages.
>>male #7: But I noticed that when you showed
the first slide with the guy's proficiency,
that he was decent at Arabic but then in the
writing, he was totally illiterate, for example.
I don't know, I think for a lot of us, if
we're going to learn Arabic or Chinese, just
screw the writing.
>>Michael Erard: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.'
[applause]